so I'm going to talk about obfuscation
my time I talk title is obfuscation from
noisily in your functional encryption
and we'll discuss what that means
okay so first let's just talk about what
aqua sketchin is so let's start with an
intuitive notion let's say that you're a
smart student at IIT Madras and you
figured out a better algorithm to factor
numbers now you could write a paper and
when the best paper rewarded crypto or
you might be more enterprising than me
at least and decide that you want to
keep the algorithm secret and sell
functionality so what you'd like to do
here is sort of take your code and input
it into some kind of a magical black box
or yellow box in my case and what should
pop out is an obfuscated code so what
this means is that lists this code which
has come out should still produce the
correct output but it should be
impossible to reverse engineer so this
is an intuitive notion of an obfuscator
and just a little bit more formally what
we're hoping to do is compile a circuit
see into a different one C hat that
preserves functionality but is
unintelligible okay so it's somehow
resistant to reverse engineering and
what do we mean by resistant to reverse
engineering so this is an obfuscator
and a notion of security is going to be
what's known as indistinguishability
obfuscation ok so this was a notion
defined by Barak at all and it says that
it should be hard to figure out which
one of two equivalent circuits c1 or c2
is obfuscated okay so let's be a little
bit careful here what do we mean by
equivalent circuits so two circuits are
equivalent if they have the same size
and the same truth table okay and what
you want is that the obfuscated version
of c1 should be interesting
from the obfuscated version of c2 so now
a moment's thought will tell you that
this is a trivial problem to solve
if efficiency is not a concern and why
is that because well if the truth tables
are the same then you can fix a
canonical circuit for every truth table
and you can just output that but our
goal in this talk and in this line of
work is to find an efficient compiler IO
ok so before we proceed it's important
to ask why do we care about this right
so it seems at least at first glance
like a reasonably you know a sort of
useless definition if we already know
that both circuits are equivalent then
does it really matter what's the
particular representation of the circuit
and it's not clear of the bad what
applications there are to this notion
but the fantastic thing is that a kind
of theorem that has emerged from the
first candidate I owe that we saw in
2013 is that IO is actually almost
crypto complete ok so what do I mean by
that so IO
since its first candidate construction
in a breakthrough work by gurga tall in
2013 has seen just an amazing number of
applications and many of these
applications are things that we really
don't know how to do any other way so it
really you know opens up this completely
fantastic set of applications and it's
even warranted its own name so you know
this land where all these amazing new
applications little is now known as
office topia okay so hopefully you will
just believe me I mean you you can go
and take a look at the literature the
reason I don't have citations on the
previous slide is that I think it's
impossible to get all the citations for
this there's just been so much work
right so hopefully you will believe me
that this is a very important notion and
the pressing question therefore before
us is does IO exist ok
so does I exist and I cannot give you a
straight answer to this question it
really depends on what you mean by exist
so it kind of I can give you a quantum
answer so it exists and doesn't exist
why because it exists because we do have
some constructions and it still doesn't
fully exist because we don't fully
understand whether it's secure
ok so let's talk about these
constructions now constructions of IO
can be categorized into these two broad
branches the first one is direct
constructions and the second one is
bootstrapping based constructions so
direct constructions are all based on
multilinear maps we'll talk in a minute
about what that is and they they more or
less use the same template in all works
so the underlying multi linear map may
vary but more or less the sort of recipe
for constructing the IO is roughly the
same and it's you know these direct
constructions have gone through a
tumultuous history to say the least I
mean there have been candidates and then
attacks on those candidates and then
fixes and then more attacks and you know
the cycle has kind of kept on and it's
been hard in general to understand
security okay and then the second type
of construction that we have is
bootstrapping based constructions so now
in my talk I'm going to primarily focus
on bootstrapping based constructions but
before that I'd like to say a few words
about these direct constructions okay so
as I told you they're all based on multi
linear map so let me tell you what those
are before they tell you about
multilinear maps let's do a quick recap
on bilinear maps which are a
tremendously useful object in
cryptography okay so here's the
definition of a cryptographic bilinear
map so we have two groups g1 and g2 of
some prime or the P and they have these
generator
little G one and little G two and a
bilinear map e that takes G 1 cross G 1
2 G 2 such that for all a be in ZP star
e of G 1 to the a g1 to the B gives you
G 2 to the a B so what is this really
letting you do what it's letting you do
is encode two elements obliviously so a
and B are you know two elements that I'm
encoding here they are going to be
hidden because of the hardness of
discrete log right because they're
sitting in the exponent and this map E
is letting me multiply these two
elements without knowing these elements
right so I apply the map and I get G 2
to the a B the hardness that I want here
is called the bilinear diffie-hellman
problem I'm not going to define it
because we're not going to use it but
let me just give you a flavor so what
this hard problem says is that well as
we saw you can compute you know degree 2
polynomials in the exponent so I showed
you that the map lets you multiply and
obviously you can add right
the hard problem says that any degree 3
computation should be indistinguishable
from random so if I have G 2 to the ABC
right then that should be
indistinguishable from a random element
all right so we have for these by linear
maps efficient instantiation from wale
and Tate pairings over elliptic curves
and these have just been enormously
useful in cryptography so for instance
they gave the first construction of
identity based encryption right so
they're very very useful and now let's
move on to multilinear maps so as you
can imagine this is a generalization of
the notion that I showed you before so
now instead of two maps or sorry instead
of two groups
I now have n groups g1 to the GN and I
have a family of Maps as you can see
here so now I can take any GI across GK
- g GI plus K right and this
by linearity property holes for the map
the difference of course is that now
when I land up in G I plus K I can keep
going
so I don't have to stop right so I can
do more than one multiplication I can
compute higher degree polynomials in the
exponent and the hardness that I'd like
is that well obviously discrete log
should be hard and hopefully there's
some generalization of bilinear D H so
you should not be able to distinguish a
product of n plus 1 elements from random
alright so some so that's kind of the
hard problem that we have so a little
bit about multi linear Maps applications
of multilinear maps would differ
described by Bonnie and Silverberg as
early as 2003 but in general there's
being pessimism about their existence in
the realm of algebraic geometry so I
should say that they exist but you know
efficiently computable ones we do not we
do not have them all right now in 2013
there was this remarkable work by Gert
gentry and Holly we that gave the first
candidate construction of these
multilinear maps and this was based on
ideal lattices using ideas inspired from
the intro crypto system and these are
immensely useful so as I already told
you they can be used to build io and
also a whole host of other things the
first construction of i/o from
multilinear maps needs maps of poly
polynomial degree ok so I'll not talk
much more about multi linear Maps
yele we'll talk about them more tomorrow
so now let's look at these bootstrapping
based constructions ok so here the sort
of philosophy is reduce reduce reduce
reduce everything as much as you can
reduce the functionality that you need
to construct are you reduce the
assumptions as much as you can and that
has been a lot of progress in this area
so let's see so as I already told you
when I
to use multilinear maps to build our you
the first constructions were using
multilinear maps of polynomial degree
then you know there there was some work
that showed us how to simplify
functionality and this was quite
surprising at the time so you you can
make do only with constant degree
multilinear maps but the assumptions
that you're using are still messy then
there was another very nice work by Lynn
and requinto Nathan which shows that you
can use constant degree multi-linear max
with nice assumptions so no longer messy
and then there was more work that shows
that this constant can actually be
reduced quite a lot so in the previous
works it was something like 30 and now
it can be reduced to something as small
as 3 and you have nice assumptions so
this is fantastic because you know
degree 3 I mean that's very very close
to degree 2 we already have degree 2 and
we have nice assumptions so you know
that's really great news but pretty soon
this excitement sort of gives way to
depression because we don't actually
have these degree 3 multi linear maps
right and where is this degree 3 barrier
coming from so just at a very very high
level we'll see more of this in the rest
of the talk but I just want to give you
a flavor essentially you know having
reduced everything as much as possible
you're going to need to somehow generate
randomness obliviously so you want to
somehow compute you know randomness
within the multi linear map and this
needs a computation of degree at least 3
this was demonstrated by some lower
bounds ok so here we have this fantastic
IO LAN which needs degree three or more
max and we know how to get degree two
maps from elliptic curve groups and what
we really like to do is bridge these two
lands because our degree tool and this
already quite cool but you know now that
we've seen applications of IO we feel
more
so we'd really like to get to this
degree three light and this is a big
open problem okay so here's my first
open problem for you
it would be a huge breakthrough if we
could construct a secure multi linear
map of degree greater than two from
algebraic geometry for instance okay all
right so that's where you know we were
with these multi linear map based
constructions a natural question to ask
is can we base our you on anything else
and it turns out yes there's another
primitive you know that we can use in
order to construct IO
and that's the primitive of functional
encryption I'm going to define it in a
second but now you also need the
functional encryption scheme to support
computation of degree at least three and
this could be good use except that
constructions of degree three functional
encryption were themselves based on
multilinear maps okay so it seems like
we're kind of back where we started but
maybe not quite so you know we're only
15 minutes into the talk so you know
there's more to come
let me tell you what functional
encryption is and then we'll see what we
can do with it so functional encryption
is this powerful primitive it it's a
generalization of public key encryption
and here's the idea so you have a safe
aircraft algorithm it outputs a master
public key and a master secret key the
encrypt algorithm is just like public
key encryption it takes some input X and
produces a ciphertext the main
difference of functional encryption from
public key encryption is the key
generation algorithm which now takes us
input this master secret key and some
function which we'll think of as a
circuit and it's going to output a
secret key corresponding to this circuit
and now in order to decrypt I am going
to put together to see the secret key
and the ciphertext and what it gives me
is
f of X and nothing else okay so remember
that public key encryption is an
all-or-nothing primitive if you have the
secret key you have the whole eggs or
you have nothing but functional
encryption lets you get this
fine-grained information so you can
actually compute functions on X and
nothing else and the notion of security
that we're going to need here is the
following so we'll play a game between a
Challenger and an adversary where the
adversary outputs to challenge messages
and receives an encryption of random one
and then the adversary gets the public
key and can make requests to the
Challenger to receive keys corresponding
to different functions it will get those
keys right and it can make let's say Q
such queries now here note that it
should be the case that F of x0 is equal
to f of x1 for any F that you query it
and why is that because well functional
encryption lets you compute f of X given
the secret key and the ciphertext so
obviously if you know the function
itself distinguishes the two messages
then you have no hope of security so
we're going to have this requirement and
then finally the attacker outputs a bit
B and once if the bit B that it output
is the same as the one chosen by the
Challenger ok so I want to quickly
remark that this definition is really
the same as the semantic security
definition for public key encryption
except that now the attacker gets access
to these secret keys right and that that
makes sense because in a functional
encryption scheme you can have these
partial decryption keys all right so now
in order to imply IO we're going to need
that the cipher text size of this
functional encryption scheme should be
sub linear in Q so if the scheme
supports Q key requests I need the
cipher text size to be sub linear in Q
ok so this this is our
succinctness requirement all right so
are you from functional encryption what
do we have here so there's been a long
sequence of works and that culminated in
the in needing a functional encryption
scheme that supports computation of
constant degree polynomials okay so as I
told you before all right and then there
were some works that showed that
actually you don't even need public key
functional encryption symmetric key
suffices okay so in this talk I'm going
to show you a new abstraction so
previously we had functional encryption
for degree at least three polynomials in
this talk I'm going to show you a weaker
notion of functional encryption which
I'm going to call noisy linear
functional encryption and I'll show you
that this actually suffices to give you
I oh okay and obviously for this to be
of any use to us this should be weaker
than you know fe4 degree three
so the theorem that we have is that a
sort of special kind of fully
homomorphic encryption scheme that can
be constructed from lwe orange lwe plus
no I say linear Fe satisfying the usual
notion of security implies IO ok so this
is what we're going to have now in this
talk I'm not at all going to talk about
this special fhe scheme I'm just going
to tell you about the nonlinear EFI I
refer you to the paper firt for this
other part
okay so nicely linear fe2 are you what
are we going to get so before I even
define it let me lay out the landscape
about where we are going right so a
nicely linear Fe using these special fhe
coatings can be bootstrap to give Fe for
P with the required succinctness and
this by the work of a J&B B implies IO
nozzle in your Fe well there were
different ways of constructing it some
of them were broken right now what
stands is broadly the following two
paths so a part number one is that you
can use the so-called notion of
partially hiding functional encryption
which can be constructed from by linear
Max and a strengthening of lwe this can
be used to instantiate noisy linear Fe
and this is actually formal so I can I
can construct a noisy linear Fe scheme
using a partially hiding functional
encryption scheme okay and Rachel I use
an a myth we'll talk about this or I
need not use bilinear maps at all and I
can just give you a direct construction
for noisy linear Fe and that's going to
be the rest of my talk all right okay so
what is this noisy linear functional
encryption scheme so before we think
about noisy linear Fe let's at least
look at what is linear Fe okay so let's
think of two vectors x and y that live
in some ring R and now I'm going to
encrypt X just as before yeah so will
you define this special fhe in this talk
or it's not I mean it's not necessary
for this talk because I'm not showing
you the bootstrapping it's it's a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme that has
certain extra structural properties so
yeah that's all I'm going to say think
of it as a kind of Fe friendliness yeah
any more questions so the reason that I
did did not want to dwell too much up
upon that part is because there there
are ways of building it just from lwe
and Ringle of Yui so
you know there's nothing there that
needs to be improved so to speak in
order to get IO so all the mess is in
this noisy linear Fe so that's why I
decided to focus on that okay yeah so
key generation is going to be as before
but now your circuit is nothing but a
vector Y so you will get some s KY and
when you put them together you should
just get X inner product Y okay and this
is a pretty sort of basic primitive you
know a very useful tool to have in your
tool kit it also admits very sort of
simple efficient and clean
instantiations it can be constructed for
instance from DDH lwe and quadratic
residue versity so now what is noisy
linear functional encryption well I just
want to add noise to the output so you
know my message is still X my function
vector is still why I want the Decrypter
to get X inner product Y plus some noise
and you know maybe you're unhappy with
the hand-waving I'm doing I mean where
does this noise come from what security
properties does it need to satisfy if I
need to add noise don't I need to
generate it if I need to generate it
isn't it like generating randomness and
isn't that high degree computation am I
going in circles well I'm going to
address these questions as we go on in
the stock questions okay all right so
noisy linear functional encryption it
actually a question could you instead
define this as X in the product grounded
X in a product Y I mean I know the ducts
would give you but you could do that as
well yes yes so I should say that we
would need to rework the bootstrapping
step but you know I I don't think that's
going to be an issue yeah
okay so here we have it as before right
so ciphertext forex keygen for Y
decryption X inner product Y plus noise
and there are at least two things that
this noise needs to satisfy so it needs
to be bounded let's say that is bounded
above by some bound actually you can
weaken this condition like you can look
at the distribution of noise more
carefully rather than just giving an
upper bound on the size but for the
purpose of this talk I'll just I just
think of it as being bounded and I'll
just use that and you would like it to
satisfy some kind of weak pseudo
randomness which we'll talk about and
the notion of security now that we need
it's similar to before but you know
there are some important differences so
first of all I'm going to only look at
the symmetric key setting so now the
adversity is also asking the Challenger
for cipher text requests okay and as
usual it's asking for key requests now
the condition that we have on the
adversity is that it should be that the
difference of inner products of you know
X 0 I and X 1 I with any key why this
difference should be bounded by some
quantity ok so again you can be more
careful and you know think of
distributions rather than a bound but
again for simplicity we'll just assume
this now just note that you know in a
standard notion of linear se you would
have this beep to be 0 right you or it
should be the difference should be equal
to 0 so the inner products should be
exactly equal so noisy linear Fe you
think that well I can request for keys
that differentiate the outputs a little
bit but the scheme should somehow add
noise and hide that difference okay so
it should still be hard for the attacker
to guess which ciphertext it receives
and the winning condition is the same
the succinct
this condition is the same so if if the
attacker asks for Q keys I need that the
cipher text size should be sub linear in
Q okay so let's look at this
all-important question of where is this
noise coming from okay so at a high
level we're going to use a PRG to
compute this noise and recall what is
the PRG so it's it's a basic object in
cryptography which takes a short random
C and stretches it into a longer
pseudo-random output okay so I'm going
to want to represent this G as a
polynomial and I want to use my Fe to
compute G of field and add it to the
output okay so it's already computing X
inner product why I wanted to
additionally add G of seed to this
output so the key new observation that
I'd like to make here is really sort of
old you know
grandmum advice which is that well if
you cannot have what you want you should
learn to want what you have repurposed
in our context what this is saying is if
you cannot compute what you can use you
should learn to use what you can compute
so what am I trying to get at I want to
be able to relax the requirement on
correctness okay so I told you I want to
use PRG to compute this noise right so
that would make the scheme look like
this but as we've already discussed I
mean this PRG computation is going to
need degree at least three if I want to
compute it exactly right so I did not
make any progress by just insisting that
you compute G of C if I do that then you
know we're not doing anything that
wasn't done before the new observation
as I tried to impute in the previous two
slides is that the requirement on
correctness now is actually much weaker
right so only X inner product Y needs to
be correct
the precise value of G of C it is not
important because it's only purpose is
to add some perturbation right and
satisfy some mild statistical property
it doesn't really matter what its
precise value is in particular if my
decryption instead of outputting X in a
product Y plus G of C if it's somehow
output some you know XY plus G prime C
prime you know for some perturbed G
Prime and C u C Prime
it's alright it's perfectly okay because
this this knowledge thing does not
really participate in correctness it
only participates in security so so far
you know we've assumed that the
polynomial is a PRG and insisted on
computing it exactly and here what we're
doing is we're saying well compute
whatever you can compute and check if it
can satisfy the statistical properties
that you need ok and this turns out to
be powerful because it permits new
direct construction so what we show is
that the linear functional encryption
scheme from lwe can be extended to noisy
linear functional encryption using new
hardness conjectures on lattices which
are very different from multi linear map
based assumptions these may be more
robust they may be post quantum in any
case they're very they're much simpler
to analyze than M map based direct
constructions and intuitively this is
because the the part of the I of
construction that's using heuristics is
kind of minimized quite a lot right so
I'm not building a direct IO scheme I'm
just building like a little component
and having built this component the rest
of the bootstrapping all the way from
noisy linear Fe to IO is all provable
security based on lwe and what's cool is
that this yields the first construction
of IO using no Maps at all so no
multilinear maps not even any by linear
maths pure lattices which makes me happy
of course we have to hope that it's
secure we will talk about that all
so let's look at the construction so
before that are there any questions
there is one question you can look at in
the spring this biaggi is said to be
weak in what sense
okay so answer lies yeah
so this PRG is weak in the sense that I
don't actually need it to produce an
output that is indistinguishable from
random what I need is that I need this
brg to satisfy some kind of a flooding a
computational slutting property so let's
say that I have some some random
variable X okay I need that X plus y
should be indistinguishable from Y where
Y is the output of the PRG and X
intuitively is that difference in the
decryption output so if you remember
when I showed you the security game of
noisy linear Fe I said that the to
challenge messages can decrypt to
slightly different values so if I think
of the difference between these
decryptions as being X then I need that
this Y should sort of computationally
flood X and actually it can be weakened
even more so I need that X plus y is
only one over poly distinguishable from
Y so Rachel and I usual like I'm sure
we'll talk much more about this okay for
my talk this is all I want to say so
just clarification about your answer to
the notes question about routing instead
of reading noise so Y is running bad
because it's high degree yes okay thanks
yes
thank you
okay so constructions so good so it's
going to be based on the ring learning
with errors problem which you know for
all those who attended the workshops
assignments the you know we've sort of
seen seen this again and again so the
ring learning with errors problem says
that it should be hard to distinguish
noisy inner products from uniform of
over a ring with suitably chosen noise
okay all right and now let's quickly
recap ray gives public key encryption
scheme or one variant of it and we're
going to repurpose that step-by-step so
first of all recall that from the SIS
problem it should be hard to find a
short vector e such that a inner product
E is U for some fixed public you okay so
using this I'm going to set my secret
key as the short vector e and I'm going
to set my public key as a nu and in
order to encrypt here's what I do so I
sample a ring element s and I compute C
0 as a s plus 2 times noise so I'm going
to use this this LSB encoding as they
say
okay so c0 is this and c1 is us plus 2
times 9 is plus my bit X okay and now
decryption is sort of very natural so I
mean I have a s plus noise us plus noise
plus X and my secret key is e and the
relation that I have is that a inner
product is u so I mean there's only one
thing you can do you can take e inner
product C 0 and that will recover for
you the the u times s term right it will
also create an inner product of the
error with e but because our e is small
so intuitively this error will not hurt
us too much
so when I subtract these two I'm going
to get X plus 2 times 0 and then I can
compute more - to recover X okay so this
is the version of Raquel's BKE that I
will use for my talk
now let's yeah I already said this so
this is small if e is small and the
ciphertext is pseudo-random by ring lwe
so now let's use this to construct
linear functional encryption ok so now I
want to encode a vector X so what's the
natural thing to do well repeat it all
times ok so now I have L elements you
want to ul and correspondingly L shot YZ
such that a e.i is UI ok I'm going to
encrypt just like before so my c0 is
exactly the same my c1 is also exactly
the same except that you know I encrypt
x coordinate by coordinate the key for a
given vector Y is going to be the inner
product of or you know the matrix vector
product of Y with this matrix of e so
summation Y ie I and now why does
decryption work ok so if I take this key
and as in the regular screen if I you
know multiply it with c0 then I'm going
to get a summation y iu is plus noise
and now I can also take Y transpose C 1
and you know similarly get this
summation Y I you I s term and this also
gives me X inner product Y right so now
when I subtract these what I end up with
is X inner product Y plus noise ok so I
can round off this noise and recover X
inner product Y ok but wait a minute
I mean decryption as I just showed you
is already giving me X inner product Y
plus noise and I just told you that I
can round off this noise and recovered X
inner product Y but I mean I
what we were going for noisy linear Fe
so why does this not do it well as you
can guess it's because this noise is not
pseudo-random okay so in particular this
noise can be fully determined after
sufficiently many key requests okay so
let's see how to add noise okay so
here's a sort of trivial starting point
idea I know how to compute X inner
product Y let's say I add a dummy
coordinate okay so I give you a fresh
encoding of noise so my X L plus 1 is
noise yl plus 1 is just 1 and now inner
product is X you know XY plus noise
which is what I wanted I can repeat this
q times once for each key request and
this is a trivial solution which
unsurprisingly does not work it will
satisfy security but it violates the
succinctness property that I told you
was needed to imply I owe right so now
my cipher text size is going to grow
with the number of key requests because
for each key I'm kind of hard coding
this noise term so this is bad all right
so this is this is not going to work for
us what I'd really like to do is I'd
like to somehow compute encoding of
noise on the fly so this you know BAM
evade yeah so if you go back you know
you're saying you need to add one
coordinates for each key request with a
fresh noise in it that's is that yeah as
a trivial solution which would satisfy
the security you want so if the
succinctness were not not a problem you
could do this and actually this was the
starting point idea of this work that I
mean you know you can do this and now I
want to somehow make it succeed so I
want to compute these encoding of noise
on the fly and what's this encoding of
noise I mean it's just a reg if encoding
it's just an lwe sample it's something
like us plus noise plus noise where now
this you know let's say us plus noise
plus noise prime right so now this noise
prime is my new message
because I want to compute an encoding of
noise right so just think of it as a
regular encoding of or lwe encoding of
noise the question is can i compute this
on the fly so yeah I mean just to remind
us again in general you you need a high
degree polynomial to compute this and we
don't have functional encryption to
support this so obviously what we're
going to try to do here is somehow
leverage this approximate computation
idea so the question is can I can I do
something better if I don't care about
the exact value and here you know enter
and true on a red carpet so now let's
see what we can do
here's an idea okay so let me now think
of two rings rp1 and rp2 as our mod p 1r
and our mod p 2i and as I told you I
want to compute an encoding of noise
that roughly looks like this so by the
way I mean this distinction of P 1 error
and noise I'm just making it for the
purpose of you know us really seeing
this noise as a message okay it's not
going to be super important in the end
but let's just stick with this
description so yeah so the noise here is
the message right and what what to do we
do now so I'm going to do the following
so I'm going to first generate a bunch
of in true Sam 'pls or in true like
samples I'll sample some short elements
F 1 I and F 2 I you know for some
polynomial polynomial I so I I is sample
in the range of I is some polynomial and
I also sample G 1 and G 2 from some
discrete from a discrete Gaussian over
the ring and I compute these and true
like samples so H 1 I is f
when I over G 1 and H 2 J is f2j over G
2 now note that unlike and true I'm
actually reusing the denominators here
and I'm going to assume that these look
random now I want to say a couple of
words about this assumption so first of
all this assumption is also implicitly
made in multi linear map based
constructions and it's never been a
source of insecurity it's also been
studied in PI codes survey on lattice
you know a decade of lattice based
cryptography so he studies this problem
in Section four point four point four so
you know you're welcome to look at that
so this this is going to be an
assumption that we make that these look
like random okay and now what we are
going to do is we're going to treat
these sort of yes you put the assumption
back up again just sort of one so oh I
see so you're saying each of all the h
1j they have the same denominator
that's right yeah so you can think of it
as a sort of bipartite graph if you will
okay so you have a bunch of H ones and a
bunch of h2s okay and all all the
vertices on one side share the same
denominator okay I see a Shwetha can can
you remind us sorry no no it's my issue
it I can you remind us remind us so the
end the intro encryption just remind us
of how that works where does the F over
G come from okay so
the way we do in true encryption is we
have just an age okay so let's say that
H is F over G and now your secret key
will be G and the public key will be H
so n true is assuming that this looks
like random and now to encrypt you do HS
plus noise plus message ok so again
let's think of HS plus 2 times noise
plus message and let's also think of age
as 2 F over G but in terms of the roles
so the H is our the public key that's
exactly right yeah the public keys so
you're sampling a bunch of public keys
except for all these public keys the g1
and g2 or that's a name yeah makes it
sort of an then okay so that's the
weekly yes okay that's true yeah a
strengthening of the assumption I mean
it's a worse assumption right so we can
either the the the not the assumption
but the security got it okay yeah right
right right so right okay good so would
you like me to finish the description no
no no no I just was I was just trying to
remember what was the role of aging
right way to think about it is if it's
different yeah okay it's I mean yeah
thanks for bringing that up because also
that's exactly how we're going to use it
in our scheme okay okay so yeah so yeah
we're going to have these you know as as
part of the key actually we're only
going to construct a symmetric key
system so but they could be public so it
doesn't hurt to have these public but
these are going to be part of the key
okay and now I want to compute you know
an encoding of noise which looks like
this right so it looks like some HS plus
noise plus the message which in this
case is also noise
now here is the main idea okay I'm going
to sample my error in a structured way
so it's my error is now not going to be
from a discrete Gaussian over the whole
ring it's actually going to live in a
principle ideal of the ring and this
principle ideal is going to be hidden so
I'm going to sample these errors from a
discrete Gaussian from from this
structured ideal and now why am I doing
this so recall this is our H 1 I and H 2
J right and now note that this error
actually if I just look at it as we
break early forgetting about the
distribution for a second so if I look
at it algebraically this error has this
you know g1 or g2 sort of built into it
okay so in particular when I multiply
this error like when I multiply e to I
with H 1 J then the G 1 term sort of
cancels out ok so what this gives me is
that as I was saying if I think of you
know this bipartite graph with now with
all the H ones and E 1 s living on one
side and the H 2 s and E 2 is living on
on the other side then all the H ones on
this side sort of annihilate with the
errors on the other side does that make
sense so the cross terms are now going
to be small ok and this is a sort of the
main new idea here so we have shown that
you know these errors are going to be
these errors when I multiply them with
the large label of the lwe sample which
is going to be H 1 I or H 2 J I am going
to end up with something small so now
what I can do is if I have these lwe
samples with sort of the structured
and the in true labels then when I
multiply them what happens is that the
cross terms do not blow up so this is a
way of you know managing our cross terms
and now when I multiply them then I get
a term that looks like this so this is
very close to the green box that we have
above right so it's you know there's
some H which is publicly computable or
in any case computable by the key
generator there is a secret it should be
t1 times t2 sorry here there's a typo
here so the secret is now t1 times 3 we
can think of that as s and there is some
noise and now this noise is sort of this
funny looking noise but we're going to
study why this noise might be okay
there are there any questions
all right so sorry I have a question
yeah it's also asked in Q&A so in the
previous lecture in true with the same
denominator assumption how large is the
W meaning how much ya security parameter
so so what's the okay thank you yeah and
actually now that you asked that so the
reason we have you know the security
parameter number of these is that I
don't I don't just want to compute this
one product so I'm going to do many of
these products and I'm going to add them
up so what this does is that you know
let's look at the sort of quadratic term
in this in in this noise here so it's G
1 G 2 times this ETA 1 ETA 2 J right so
now this if I ignore the P 1 this lives
in this ideal G 1 G 2 and this ideal
should be hidden so I don't want the
adversary when she decrypts I don't want
her to recover all the noise terms
living in the same principle idea so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
this many many times and add it up right
and this will this will randomize the G
1 G 2 so I'm going to have many copies
of this and I'm going to add them all up
so the noise will then get spread out
over the ideas so may I also ask this
question is it enough to recover the
idea to break the scheme law if there
were only one idea then yes so what I'm
showing you
is a simplified version of the scheme as
I discussed this later
in the real scheme that we have there's
not just one g1 and g2 so right now what
I showed you is just this one bipartite
graph where there's a single G 1 and a
single G 2 but we also repeat that
security parameter number of times so
now there are you know there are lambda
copies of g1 g2 all of them are
different okay and now when I add I do
these multiplications and then I add up
these encoding so the noise term that
results is going to roughly be like a
summation of you know G 1i g 2j times nu
randomness so this is if you didn't have
the you know G 1 G twos at all then this
would be sort of noise that's
distributed like in the regular ring lwe
case you do have now these g1 s and g2 s
but to mitigate the effect that it lives
in a principle ideal if I only do it
once like if I only have one bipartite
graph then there's a single principle
like ug 1 times G 2 but if I have lambda
many of them then I have the adversities
actually recovered recovering a noise
which now is a summation of noise terms
that live in these ideals so it again
the noise spreads out over the whole
ring so if you could recall so this is
no longer the principle ideal problem so
even quantumly we don't know how to
solve it if you could recover these
secret elements then it would be a
problem for security but we don't know
how to do it ok yeah so the key idea as
I said the key first idea in this
construction is that the noise lives in
an ideal that cancels the large term in
a ring LW sample and the nice thing here
is that there's no need to stop at 2 so
you know with all lattice based
constructions if you can do degree 2
you can you know do more and that's also
the case here so there's no restriction
of map or anything you can kind of keep
going okay so the theorem is that it's
easy to make noise the description that
I gave you is oversimplified I show I
also described one other idea that we
use there are also more ideas so for
instance you know remember what's our
secret key so our secret key is a short
vector that maps some matrix to another
vector right or some vector to some
matrix to another vector now what we can
also do is that this short vector which
is the key can also do an approximate
mapping so that's a way for even the key
to add noise into the decryption
equation so there are multiple ways in
which you can add to this noise term
that the adversary recovers okay so what
about security so now this is of course
the most important question and sort of
roughly speaking there are two axes on
on which we need to think the first is
just the semantic security of the
encoding so these encoding czar sort of
non-standard encoding they're using this
you know n true label and they're using
the structured noise are they secure
that's one question the second thing is
that I'm using these non-standard
encodings to compute these encoding zuv
noise in the on the fly which will
finally be plugged in to my linear EFI
scheme right and then the adversary is
going to actually learn X inner product
Y plus noise where noise is the stuff
that I generated right so does this
noise serve the weak pseudo randomness
property that it needs to serve so these
are sort of the two questions that we
have and let me tell you a little bit
about security so I see that I am
running out of time so I'll maybe just
say a few words so in the
first work from last euro crypt where we
introduced this scheme we did some
analysis and we tried to do a proof but
it doesn't quite work out I mean we get
a proof from a really clumsy assumption
in a very weak security game where the
attacker only gets a single ciphertext
and security unfortunately is based on
the inability to find attacks this is
you know a bit unsurprising giving
lattice given lattice based proof
techniques but the good news is that
it's it's still a much simpler system to
analyze than previous direct
constructions it minimizes the part that
depends on heuristics it uses no Maps
and has a different design template and
it has a chance of being post quantum so
in a follow-up work with Alice we did
much more rigorous script analysis and
we did find two problems with the scheme
which we could fix so these two problems
in my view even though they're sort of
serious problems in that they break the
scheme in my view they're not
fundamental problems so you know the fix
is not very complicated and the scheme
does not change very much with the fix
we also suggest concrete parameters we
develop new cryptanalytic techniques and
we feel that the security is on a much
firmer footing after this work so I
would hope is that this inspires new
candidates okay so we know how much more
time can I take so formally we are kind
of out of time so maybe this is a good
time to sit if I stop and ask questions
so we can all right sound sounds good so
let me just wrap up then yeah so I don't
I won't have time to go into the
tax or you know or the fix so let me
just tell you that the first attack had
to do with the commutativity of these
polynomials so in some sense you know
the way we set it up the the structured
noise in highlights the large term not
only in its own ciphertext but also in
other ciphertext so this ends up being a
problem and you can fix this by making
it non commutative and the second attack
I want to just say a couple of words
about it so yeah like if you or maybe
I'll show you the other slide which has
the noise term yeah so you know yeah
this is what the noise term looks like
for degree two of course our final noise
will be of higher degree than two but in
the original scheme I had this tower of
moduli and what this tower of module I
was doing is it was sort of
inadvertently creating these layers
between the noise so the noise as you
can see is like this large complex
polynomial equation which is good that's
what we want right and the focus had
been on sort of getting like a high
degree term but what ends up happening
is because of these you know public
module light that separate these noise
terms you can actually recover them
separately and then there's a kind of a
rank attack that can be launched but
this can be fixed by not having these
different module lines so I feel that
this is yeah so there is a natural way
to fix it you don't need to have these
different module I so you can go back to
an error term which looks you know
pretty it looks like a high degree
polynomial equation spread as I said so
it each term lives in one ideal but it's
going to be a linear combination over
many ideals so if you can see here
there's you know G 1 L and G 2 L so
there are many of these else right there
are security parameter many of them so
it's also this high degree polynomial
which is spread out over the whole ring
and if you didn't have these secret
ideals as I already said before this
would be a good noise term with no
problems it would just be like a gold
right PR G noise term but we do have
these secret ideals we mitigate their
effect by having many of them and just
adding them all up so sort of thereby
not not letting the adversary separate
them and leverage them leverage any
structure so yeah this is the final
slide as I said you know we did find a
couple of problems in the scheme but in
my view it's it's not a fundamental
vulnerability this scheme that we have
can help us to compute super
polynomially large noise so you can you
know flood the noise in the original
scheme easily and it's a new design
methodology and it's my hope that we'll
get more more candidates for the subject
so what's open is proof from simple
assumptions from purely lwe this seems
quite difficult but I cannot say that
it's impossible there is by the way some
negative evidence there are some lower
bounds that show that I you cannot be
constructed from sort of all-or-nothing
primitives or assumptions like lwe but I
won't go into that now we'd like to see
more candidates and we'd also like to
see better efficiency so if all of this
you know works out if everything is
secure it's still a monster so you know
it's no we're in a place where it can be
implemented at this moment so it's also
good to have schemes that are more
efficient thank you
[Applause]
so so we have to talks to questions and
we are in the the Q&A can noises for two
different computations be correlated
would this be a problem so this is a
very good question so the noises from
two different computations can indeed be
correlated but this correlation is
inherent to a PRG
isn't it so if I have a PRG it only has
a short seat but I'm still generating a
long output so obviously sort of each
output noise is correlated right all the
output noises are correlated and that's
also going to be the case here but what
we do here there is no worse than what's
already happening in a PRG second
question Fe plus noise yeah so you
should answer this but we should kind of
keep on time so it's maybe a quick
answer and then we okay yeah
Fe plus noise CTD continued maybe yes I
thought about linear while in eeeh okay
so I don't follow the question so let's
see let's dismiss yeah let's take this
offline or something okay all right
let's thanks for it should again and
we'll reconvene at 9:45 so that's in
nine minutes for Rachel's talk